يبدا رئيس وزراء العراق محمد شاه السوداني
زياره الى مصر للقاء عدد من كبار
المسؤولين في اطار دعم العلاقات الثنائيه
بين البلدين واشارت وسائل الاعلام محليه
الى ان الزياره المرتقبه سيكون بها توقيع
الاتفاقيات والعديد من مذكرات التفاهم بين
الدولتين مضيحه ان السوداني سيبحث العديد
من الملفات من بينها التبادل التجاري
ومشروع الربط الكهربائي والنفط والغاز
وزياده نسب الاستثمار المتبادل بين العراق
ومصر وحول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
القاهره مراسل العربيه احمد عثمان اهلا بك
احمد يعني ما المعلومات المتوفره حتى الان
حول هذه الزياره التوقيت والشخصيات التي
سيلقاها
في انتظار اعلان وصول لرئيس الوزراء
العراقي الى مصر هذه الزياره معلنه منذ
ايام فيما يتعلق بالشق السياسي هي الزياره
الاولى على مستوى الثنائي هو كان قد التقى
مع الرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي في عمان وتم
ايضا في بغداد هناك من يرى بان هذا هو
استكمال لما يراه البعض او ما يراه محللون
بالانفتاح العراقي على المحيط العربي
والذي بدا في عهد سلفه السيد مصطفى
الكاظمى كما ذكرتي بالفعل هذه الزياره
تحمل اكثر من عنوان ربما العنوان
الاقتصادي هو الابرز فيها فيما يتعلق
بالعلاقات الثنائيه فيما يتعلق بامور مثل
النفط والغاز في التبادل التجاري الرابط
الكهربائي كان الكثير من هذه الامور تم
مناقشتها خلال الحكومه السابقه برئاسه
السيد مصطفى الكاظمي وهناك ربما رغبه في
استكمارها او ربما تطويرها فيما يتعلق
بالوضع الاقتصادي المصري وايضا الوضع
الاقتصادي في الاقليم هناك ايضا من يرى
بان هناك جانب امني في العلاقه ما بين
البلدين فيما يتعلق بمواجهه الارهاب
وغيرها وايضا فيما يتعلق بالتنسيق فيما
يتعلق بالتحديات التي تواجه المنطقه بشكل
عام فيما يتعلق بالجزء الاخير من سؤالك
فمن المفترض ان يكون هناك بالتاكيد لقاء
مع الرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي وربما سيكون
هناك مؤتمر صحفي وتوقيع عدد من مذكرات
التفاهم حيث علمنا بان الوفد العراقي يدوم
مجموعه كبيره من الوزراء ايضا كان هناك
معلومات بانه قد يكون هناك زياره الى
مشيخه الازهر ولقاء مع الامام احمد الطيب
الامام الاكبر كان من المفترض ان يكون
هناك ايضا زياره الى جامعه الدول العربيه
ولقاء مع السيد احمد ابو الغيط امين وها
العام ولكن اخترنا بان هذه الزياره تم
الغاءها بسبب ضغط جدول الاعمال المتعلق
بزياره رئيس الوزراء العراقي الى القاهره